now we are going to turn our attention
to russia
in the second half the back half of this
hour but i want to start
on covid
and our response to covid and the
backlash that is finally happening
against over-the-top unscientific
safety-ism
barry weiss
is a former new york times
editor
she famously left that newspaper in a
blaze of glory wrote a scathing
resignation letter
and she's gone independent she's got a
sub stack i think she's really
interesting she's left of center
but she's not a conservative she is
strongly against the woke crowd
so we respect her a lot for that she
fights them all the time and she
was on bill maher's show
friday night real time
and she went on a bit of a rant that
went everywhere
she said that she has had enough she is
over it
she explained why
and listen to the audience reaction
throughout this this is a notoriously
left-wing audience out there in la for
bill maher
she had a lot of the crowd behind her as
she said this in cut 14. i'm done
get this question no i'm done with
kovitz i'm done it's like i i went so
hard on kovid i yeah i remember read the
pringles cans that i bought at the
grocery store stripped my clothes off
because i thought kovid would be on my
clothes like i did it all i watched
tiger king i got to the end of spotify
like
we all did it right
and no no we didn't all do it well
here's the thing a lot we didn't know a
lot of us did do it and then we were
told you get the vaccine you get the
vaccine and you get back to normal
and
we haven't gotten back to normal
and it's ridiculous at this point
i know that so many of my liberal and
progressive friends are with me on this
and they do not want to say it out loud
because they are scared to be called
anti-vaxx or to be called science denial
or to be you know smeared as a trumper
i'm sorry if you believe the science you
will look at the data that we did not
have two years ago and you will find out
that cloth masks do not do anything
so she's clearly on a roll here and she
didn't stop there barry weiss continues
cut 15. you will realize that you can
show your vaccine passport at a
restaurant and still be asymptomatic and
carrying omicron and you will realize
most importantly that this is going to
be remembered by the younger generation
as a catastrophic moral crime
the city of flint michigan which is 80
percent i think minority students has
just announced indefinite virtual
schooling in the past two years we've
seen among young girls a 51 increase in
self-harm people are killing themselves
they are anxious they are depressed they
are lonely
that is why we need to end it more than
any inconvenience that it's been to the
rest of us i think
okay
it's like at this point
it's a pandemic of bureaucracy it's a
pandemic of bureaucracy it's not it's
not real anymore it's a pandemic of
bureaucracy big crowd we need to end it
i'm over it she said
what's the phrase into my veins directly
into my veins that's how i felt watching
that from barry weiss and she speaks for
so many people
so many people who did everything they
were told and then it never seems to
quite end
and these neurotic people
who keep pretending that the data isn't
the data and their
made-up version of science is the real
science there are still far too many of
them calling the shots
so that clip went round the world
and got a lot of attention a lot of
applause but some people are not happy
about it including
jimmy acosta over at cnn who got demoted
into a weekend show
i don't know how many people watch cnn
on the weekends uh but he's got that
show and oh he was not not pleased at
all with barry weiss how can she say
that take it away jim cut 16. i'm done
with that attitude honestly i mean you
know i mean she needs to understand that
trolling people to own the libs is not a
sacrifice
she is a lib jim
just like you
jim acosta of course a progressive
activist
with a press badge
i'm done with that attitude oh how brave
of you
so brave
jim acosta here's the thing jimmy
if you don't like
what barry wise said and you feel like
everyone should be in eight masks
and they should be required just to go
out and live their lives to have like
every booster shot from now until
eternity you
jiminy can live your life that way
you don't i guarantee you you don't by
the way
but you could if that's what you want
for you and your family go for it
knock yourself out don't force that on
everyone else
we've had enough
i'm so pro-vaccine everyone who listens
to this show knows it i got double
vaccinated
then i got covered it was pretty mild
i will talk to my doctor next month six
months later whether it's time for a
booster whether that makes sense for me
i'm going to address that with my doctor
i'm leaning towards doing it
i am pro-vaccine i am also
done
like barry weiss is i've had enough
we'll talk about it later in the show i
was just in texas where things were
sensible and normal
and you can make decisions for yourself
as an adult
and then i flew to new york which is
where i am now and it's like oh welcome
back to rulesville even if the rules
make absolutely no sense
so bill maher on that same show made a
joke that made some ladies on the view
very angry oh they were angry here's
what mars said friday night on hbo cut
23. i don't want to live in your
paranoid world anymore your masked
paranoid world you know you go out it's
silly now you know you have your mask
you have to have a card you have to have
a booster they scan your head
like you're a
cashier and i'm a bunch of bananas
i'm not bananas you are
so hoopy goldberg at the view who with
all due respect knows so little
about this stuff
like some of her comments in recent
weeks shows that she knows
so
so little about the data and the science
but that does not prevent her
from waltzing into a studio and talking
to millions of women every day
and spreading a bunch of fear and
paranoia based on not data
with a lot of self-righteousness she was
big mad at bill maher for that joke cut
24 this was today that's
not really funny to people who've lost
their kids
to this vaccine of people who've lost
family members or
dear friends to this it's it's just you
know listen nobody on the planet really
wants to go through this this is not
something we're doing because it's you
know sexually gratifying this is what
we're doing to protect our families and
you don't have to do it but stay away
from everybody because if you're the one
who's
not paying attention
and you're coughing and sneezing you
don't want to
then stay out of the public man this is
not nobody wants this no no i don't want
it this is the thing i think he's
forgetting that people are still this is
the thing whoopee
if you
want to do all these things and want to
be super quote-unquote safe even though
that's not what the data shows or the
science you should be the one at this
point isolating yourself from society
don't force the rest of us to live that
way
don't force the rest of us to live that
way and it is so cheap and unfair to
pretend that being critical of dumb
baseless nonsense restrictions is
somehow being cavalier and callous
towards the people who've died of their
families of course not we give the
number every day on this show
people who have died from this
although she talked about kids
it's been a tiny vanishingly small
number of kids
far more kids have died in car accidents
and in swimming pool drownings than from
covid so to talk about kids again that's
just like another example of
fear-mongering and spreading
garbage to try to pull at people's
heartstrings and make them afraid
you say oh well putting that stat into
context that's cruel that's callus no
it's not it's about
risk assessment which is what public
policy is whoopi
so she's all indignant
over bill maher saying we have to get
back to something
much closer to normal and we cannot keep
doing these
superstitious rituals
that don't align with the data but
whoopi was very angry about that and
then one of her co-hosts
went on
to say this in cut 25. they're over it
like yeah my relationship i'm over it i
don't feel like i don't think anymore to
the post-mask part because i think
there's a prudence we've learned with
the mask the hand sanitate
hand sanitizing that kind of like 911
with flying is always going to be here
now there's a new normal in the
beginning when at post 911 people didn't
want to fly and the security measures
felt like uh how do we do this you know
and now it's the norm i think some of
the things we've learned in this
pandemic are going to stay the same i
may never ride a subway again without a
mask i may never go indoors to big
crowds and never feel comfortable
without a mask and that's up to me to do
that
that's sarah haynes
again if that's what she wants to do for
the rest of her life
she says it's prudent because she's
scared to wear a mask everywhere she
goes indoors and crowds your call sarah
don't impose that on everyone else
especially don't impose that on children
where there are harms to children for
forcing them to wear masks for hours
every day and there are not proven
benefits
and it doesn't stop the virus
and kids by virtue of being kids are
basically vaccinated against this
disease because almost none of them who
contract it get even moderate let alone
severe
symptoms
let alone die
the problem is they're having that
conversation on the view and they all
agree they're out of step now at this
point with most of the country
and they want to take their fears and
their so-called solutions that are not
based on science and make that what we
have to do across the country in the
name of safety and health
and they want to do it indefinitely as
she said
this might become the new normal no
masking especially of children
cannot become the new normal this
mentality what you just heard there from
the ladies at the view
has to be actively resisted and defeated
more on that when we come back as we
just get started on this monday it's the
guy benson show